THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
IT'S A BATTLE OF BIG IDEAS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2020
DEMOCRATS CLASHING ON KEY ISSUE
ISSUES.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SAYS
IT'S TAKING A BIG STEP TOWARDS
ENDING CATCH AND RELEASE BY
SCRAPPING THE FLORES AGREEMENT
WHICH LIMITS THE AMOUNT OF TIME
MIGRANT FAMILIES CAN BE
DETAINED.
TRUMP SAYING HE COULD END
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
YOU HAVE A BABY ON OUR LANDS,
THE BABY IS NOW U.S. CITIZEN.
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT VERY, VERY
SERIOUSLY.
FRANKLY IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Jesse: 2020 DEMOCRATS ARE
SHORT ON ACTUAL SOLUTIONS BUT
HAVE PLENTY OF INSULTS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY ARE GETTING AN ASSIST FROM
THE MEDIA.
CHECK IT OUT.
>> THIS PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY
DETERMINED TO CARRY OUT MAXIMUM
CRUELTY ON LITTLE CHILDREN WHO
ARE BROWN.
>> THEY WOULD RIP KIDS FROM THE
BOSOMS OF THEIR MOTHERS.
>> IT'S A RIDICULOUS NOTION TO
OVERTURN THE 14TH AMENDMENT.
IT'S A RACIST ON ITS FACE.
HE IS TRYING TO DRIVE US APART,
MAKE US ANGRY.
>> IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND KIDS
WILL BE HELD INDEFINITELY AT THE
PLEASURE OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
KIND OF LIKE GUANTANAMO.
>> EVERYTHING ABOUT IMMIGRATION
HE HAS DONE TO SCARE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: IS IT LITERALLY LIKE
GUANTANAMO, JUDGE?
THOSE BABIES, SO LUCKY TO BE
AMERICAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: A QUARTER OF
A MILLION BABIES ARE BORN IN THE
UNITED STATES WHO ARE SO-CALLED
ANCHOR BABIES.
THE COST OF THIS COUNTRY'S TWO
AND A QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE WORLD'S GROSS -- TO THE
HOSPITALS.
THE 14TH AMENDMENT MAKES IT VERY
CLEAR THAT YOU ARE A CITIZEN IF
YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO'S IN THE
UNITED STATES AND SUBJECT TO THE
JURISDICTION THEREOF.
THE KEY CASE --
IS THAT HAIR SPRAY?
>> Juan: YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU,
JUDGE.
I'M HELPING YOU OUT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE KEY CASE
INVOLVED AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
PARENTS WERE CHINESE AND HE WAS
BORN IN THE UNITED STATES WHILE
THEY WERE HERE AND THEY WOULDN'T
LET HIM BACK AND WHEN HE LEFT
THE COUNTRY.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID LOOK,
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
HIS PARENTS HAVE A LEGAL RIGHT
TO BE HERE AND THEREFORE WERE
GOING TO LET HIM BE A CITIZEN.
THEY HAVE NEVER ACTUALLY
ANSWERED THE QUESTION WHICH IS
ON EVERYONE'S MINDS RIGHT NOW
AND THAT IS CAN YOU BECOME A
CITIZEN IF YOUR MOTHER IS NINE
MONTHS PREGNANT, JUMPS OVER THE
WALL AND GIVES BIRTH?
>> Jesse: JUAN, THE AUTHOR OF
THE 14TH AMENDMENT SAID IT WAS
PRIMARILY DIRECTED AT SLAVES,
NOT DISCUSSING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OR SONS AND DAUGHTERS
OF AMBASSADORS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> Juan: JUSTICE WATERS, I'M
GUESSING YOU'RE HAVING AN
ARGUMENT IF THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Jesse: THOSE PEOPLE WERE
LEGAL RESIDENTS.
>> Juan: YOU KEEP TALKING AND
HURTING YOURSELVES.
>> Jesse: I FEEL FINE.
>> Juan: REPUBLICANS SAYING
THE PRESIDENT SHOULDN'T BE
DISCUSSING THIS AND THAT THIS IS
ESTABLISHED LAW.
SUPREME COURT LAW.
NOT LOWER COURTS, THE
SUPREME COURT HAS SAID UNDER THE
14TH AMENDMENT, CHILD BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES IS AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
NOT SUBJECT TO DEBATE.
THE LARGER POINT HERE IS ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO GO
AFTER AND TRY TO DEMONIZE
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY AS A
POLITICAL STIR FOR HIS BASE.
I SAW HIS NUMBERS IN THE
AP POLL, DOWN TO 36% APPROVAL.
HE IS LOOKING FOR ANYTHING,
ANYTHING THAT HE CAN TO FIND A
WAY TO GIN UP SUPPORT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY IDEAS ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT!
>> Juan: NO IDEAS.
>> Greg: PORTABLY BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR THREE YEARS?
MY GOD.
YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING FOR
5 MINUTES.
>> Juan: HIS ONLY IDEA HAS
BEEN BUILD A WALL AND HE HASN'T
EVEN DONE THAT.
>> Greg: HERE IS THE ISSUE
THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM, IT'S
NOT JUST WITH IMMIGRATION.
IT'S HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER
PROBLEMS.
THE LEFT ADHERES TO ONE SINGULAR
STRATEGY AND THAT IS ANY KIND OF
PROCESS, ANY KIND OF LAW, ANY
KIND OF LOGIC OR ANY KIND OF
REASON IS A SYMPTOM OF CRUELTY.
YOU WILL BE ACCUSED OF
DEMONIZING.
IF YOU WANT TO HELP THE HOMELESS
OFF THE STREET, YOU DEMONIZE.
IF YOU WANT TO ENFORCE YOUR
BORDER, YOU DEMONIZE.
THIS ONLY HAPPENS WHEN THE OTHER
SIDE IS IN CHARGE, RIGHT?
THE REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE ONCE
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN CHARGE,
THEY START ACTING LIKE ADULTS.
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT OB
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT OM
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT OA
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT OT
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT OD
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT OL
PRESIDENT           PRESIDENT ON
ADULT AND HE WAS SAYING THE SAME
THING PRESIDENT TRUMP THE SAME.
A PROCESS, RULES AND
ENFORCEMENT, ADULTS GET THIS.
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMS, YOU
CANNOT TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
YOU COULDN'T TELL WHICH WAS IN
THE MEDIA ON WHICH WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE SAME ANIMAL.
I MEAN ANIMAL PURELY AS A
METAPHOR.
>> Sandra: I FEEL LIKE I HAVE
TO RAISE MY VOICE TO MAKE MY
POINT.
>> Greg: WELL, THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
>> Sandra: ACTUAL WORDS, OBAMA
REFERRED TO ACTING DHS
SECRETARY, WE HAD ON
"AMERICA'S NEWSROOM" ."
A SIGNIFICANT STEP IN ADDRESSING
THE CORE ASPECT OF THE CRISIS IN
THE BORDER.
OBAMA'S FORMER BORDER PATROL
CHIEF, MARK MORGAN WAS ON THIS
MORNING, SAID THIS IS A
GAME CHANGER.
THIS WILL ABSOLUTELY ELIMINATE
AT LEAST PART OF THE BORDER
CRISIS BUT YOU REWIND ONE YEAR
AGO WHEN JEH JOHNSON, OBAMA'S
DHS SECRETARY MADE THE POINT
THAT FLORES IS AN ISSUE.
IT'S A LOOPHOLE THAT HAS TO BE
CLOSE.
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE MEDIA,
INDEFINITE PERIOD OF TIME,
SUPREME COURT RULING, 2001, 180
DAYS IS THE LONGEST PERIOD OF
TIME.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT 50 TO 60
DAYS THAT THEY NEED TO PROPERLY
PROCESS THE MIGRANTS.
>> Juan: WHAT WE HAVE ON THE
TABLE SHOULD BE HOW DO WE
PROPERLY PROCESS AND DEAL WITH
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS ASYLUM LAWS AND WE WANT TO
HOLD TO THE LAW.
GREG TALKS ABOUT LET'S DO
EVERYTHING BY THE BOOKS, BY THE